[تصفيق]
تصفيقات حاره في البدايه وحمى انتكاسه في
نهايه التصويت مجلس النواب الامريكي في
حاله لم تحدث منذ قرن اكثر من جلسه تصويت
واكثر من محاوله فاشله للمرشح الجمهوري
كيفن مكارثي للظفر بمصب الرئيس رئيس مجلس
النواب هو ثالث اهم شخصيه في الولايات
المتحده بعد الرئيس ونائبه فوضى وانقسامات
الجمهوريين جعلت التصويت هذه المره امرا
عسيرا الحزب الفائز بالاغلبيه في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي الاخيره يعجز عن لم شمله
واصلاح شرخه يحتاج المرشح لمنصب رئيس مجلس
النواب الى 2008 صوتا وعدد مقاعد
الجمهوريين في المجلس الحالي
222 لماذا لا يقنع مكارثي عضو الكونجرس عن
ولايه كاليفورنيا رفقه الجمهوريين بالنسبه
للجناح اليمنيه المتشدد في حزب فهو متهم
بعدم الولاء بدرجه كافيه للرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب ترامب نفسه اعرب عن دعمه
لمكارسي في منشور له على موقع
كتب ان الوقت قد حان كي يصوت جميع
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب لصالح انتخابي
كيفن مكارثي رئيسا
تنازلات مكه الاخيره ووعده بفتح تحقيقات
ضد الرئيس جوبيدا وعائلته
ومكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي في حال فوزه لم
تشفع له لدى خصومه والمفارقه انه كل ما رد
خالي مطالبهم فقد اصوات اخرى من المعتدلين
داخل حزبه كان البيت الجمهوري من بعد حقبه
ترامب مكتوب عليه الازمات الداخليه يمكن
الانتخابي رئيس مجلس النواب ان يستدعي
اكثر من جوله اختراعه وان يستغرق ساعات او
اسابيع
في عام
1923 اختير رئيس المجلس بعد عده جولات
اقتراع وفي عام
1856 تحقق انتخاب الرئيس بعد الشهرين و
133 جوله اختراع صوت الرئيس بيضا لم يضم
طويلا بتصريحات منتقده لما يجري قال ان
فوضى تصويت الجمهوريين على رئيس مجلس
النواب لا تعكس صوره جيده للولايات
المتحده وهي محرجه مؤكدا بان التصويت على
رئيس مجلس النواب ليس مشكلته عدم التصويت
قد يكون نعمه الله في حال الشلل التشريعي
قد يلقي بالله ما على الجمهوريين
المسؤولين عن التعطيل وطبعا كله امل في
قلب الامور لمصلحه ادارته
بعد دعوات للخلوه والتكاتف وجمع الصفوف
لتجاوز الهزيمه الكارثيه لمكرتي في
الجولات الاربعه كيف سيتجاوز الجمهوريون
تشرمهم اختيار خليفه نانسي في مجلس النواب
الامريكي هو الاصعب منذ 100 عام